chào các bạn video này sẽ hướng dẫn các
bạn các cái thao tác trên đối tượng
table hay còn gọi là bản
biểu cụ thể là chúng ta sẽ lập một cái
bản như thế này và thực hiện một vài các
thao tác định dạng bây giờ bắt đầu nha À
chúng ta tạo bảng thì chúng ta vào thẻ
Insert chọn table Sau đó chúng ta ra
chuột để xác định kích cỡ của bạn và
chúng ta đếm là bên này là có tổng cộng
là năm cột này chúng ta ra qua 5 ô còn
bao nhiêu dòng thì không quan trọng
Chúng ta sẽ bổ sung sau hoặc là loại bỏ
sau Ví dụ chúng ta tạo ra là năm cột năm
dòng đi chúng ta ra chuột nha chứ không
nhấp chuột rồi khi nào xác định kích cỡ
xong mình nhấp rồi chúng ta có được cái
bản à thao tác tiếp theo là chúng ta sẽ
xác định độ rộng của mỗi cột thì chúng
ta quan sát trong bảng này á thì cột
loại tiền gửi á là nó rộng hơn các cái
cột còn lại thì chúng ta sẽ mở rộng ra
bằng cách trỏ chuột vào cái đường phân
cách giữa cột 1 và cột 2 khi nào c rõ
chuột có mũi tên là hai chiều nằm ngang
thì chúng ta kéo qua phải mở rộng cột 1
và đồng thời nó thu hẹp cột
2 bây giờ tiếp tục là mở rộng cột 1 rồi
thì các cái cột còn lại này B cột 2 3 4
5 bốn cái cột này này độ rộng nó sẽ như
nhau thì chúng ta
sẽ thao tác chúng ta không ngồi Chúng ta
mở rộng các cái cột như thế này thì
chúng ta thao tác như thế này nó không
chính xác và chúng ta làm bằng cách như
th này n chúng ta trỏ vào đường phía
trên của cột thứ hai nhắc chuột thao tác
này là để chọn sau đó chúng ta kéo qua
bên
phải để chúng ta chọn bốn cái cột đó Bây
giờ muốn độ rộng bốn cột này như nhau
thì chúng ta sẽ vào thẻ là table layout
và chúng ta chọn lệnh là distribute
colum thao tác này là nó sẽ cho độ rộng
bốn cột là bằng nhau hết nhắp đây Các
bạn thấy nó bằng nhau đây nha Và bây giờ
chúng ta bắt đầu gõi dữ liệu vào ô đầu
tiên chúng ta sẽ gõ vào đây là loại tiền
gửi g tình gửi chúng ta nhập vào và ô
tiếp theo là chúng ta sẽ gõ vào là trả
lạii cuối kỳ
và sau đó là mở ngoặc
ra mở ngoặc ra và chúng ta chọn gõ tiếp
là phần trăm
tháng và động vặt lại thì chúng ta thấy
nó từ Đồng nó rớt dò
nha do cái phong chữ nó lớn mình sửa lại
một chút 12 đây nó tự động nó rớt dòng
và bây giờ á
là chúng ta sẽ gõ tiếp một là mã pháp
nhân rồi và chúng ta có cái thao tác này
chúng ta phải nối các Cái ô này lại
thành một ô giống như bản bên này thì
chúng ta chọn 5 ô này và chúng ta vào
table layout và chúng ta chọn lệnh m
sell đây thì nó sẽ nối lại ha tiếp tục
và chúng ta sẽ gõ tiếp vào là tiền gửi
thanh toán nội dung vân vân thì bây giờ
cái bảng này nó đang còn thiếu dòng này
chúng ta muốn thêm dòng thì chúng ta có
hai cách cách một á thì chúng ta trọ vào
V vị trí cuối cùng nó xuất hiện dề cộng
này chúng ta nhấp chuột này Đây nó thêm
dòng nó thêm dòng vào cho mình và cách
thứ hai á là chúng ta đặt trỏ vào ô cuối
cùng góc bên phải của bản chúng ta nhấn
phím Tab trên phần phím
ấy đây nó C thêm dòng cho mình đây nha
và ví dụ đây là phần mục hai là
mã pháp nhân
à file mã là pháp
nhân trên này là cá nhân chứ không phải
pháp nhân sửa
làm rồi và tiếp tục dòng dưới cùng này
là tiền gửi có kỳ hàng
rồi và đó là chúng
ta thiết kế cái bả và chúng ta nhập dữ
liệu vào và bây giờ là chúng ta sẽ thực
hiện tiếp cái thao
tác chúng ta thực hiện tiếp cái thao tác
Á là nối năm Cái ô này lại thì chúng ta
chọn năm ô chúng ta vào t layout chúng
ta chọn m sale hoặc là nhấp phải vào
chúng ta chọn là m sale
nhấ đấy nó nối lên cho chúng ta Này bây
giờ tiếp tục là chúng ta tiến hành là kẻ
khung kẻ khung thì cái đường ngoài cùng
của cái bản biểu này là nét đôi này cái
đường trong là nét đơn thì chúng ta thao
tác chọn bản chúng ta nhắp chuột vào cái
nút này này đây cái nút này góc trên bên
trái của bả nhắp vào chúng ta chọn bả
xong chúng ta kẻ không thì chúng ta vào
thẻ home chúng ta chọn lệnh là border
anding nhắp Border chọn Border and shing
giống như chúng ta kẻ khung một đoạn văn
vậy thôi Và bây giờ tiếp tục là chúng ta
sẽ chọn cái mục O là nó kẻ khung cho
chúng ta là đường ngoài cùng và đường
những đường ở trong bây giờ muốn kẻ nét
đôi thì chúng ta nhấp vào Style chúng ta
chọn nét
đôi
và chúng ta có thể chọn nét đậm một chút
vễ quán
sát
đó mục đích là dễ quán sát
nha rồi tiếp tục bây giờ chúng ta muốn
là đường trong là nét đơn thì chúng ta
hãy bỏ cái đường trong bằng cách á là
trỏ vào cái hình minh họa bên này này
chúng ta nhắp vào đường ngang này nhắp
vàoo đường dọc này để bỏ đây nhắp cứ
nhắp vào để bỏ Sau đó chúng ta chọn lại
cái đường đơn và chúng ta lại nhắp vào
vị trí như lúc nãy để chúng ta tạo lại
đấy nhắp vào để tạo Nha mà chưa được thì
chúng ta cứ nhắc chuột vào rồi chúng ta
chọn Ok để hoàn tắt như vậy chúng ta có
được cái bảng mà đường ngoài cùng là nét
đôi và đường trong là nét nét đơn bây
giờ thao tác tiếp theo chúng ta là chọn
nền định dạng nề chúng ta chọn cái dòng
chúng ta vào lệnh Sing chúng ta chọn nền
giống như chúng ta kẻ khung thông thường
và cái dòng cá nhân Vậy chúng ta chọn
Nền màu nền nhạt hơn một
chút phạp nhân chọn
tiếp tục là chúng ta sẽ định
dạng định dạng cái dòng tiêu đề này dòng
tiêu đề này chúng ta quan sát này cái
dòng loại tiền ngửi này nó canh giữa
nhưng mà vừa canh giữa theo chiều ngang
mà vừa canh giữa theo chiều dặc Nếu
chúng ta thực hiện thao tác C giữa Thông
thường thì nó chỉ cân giữa theo chiều
ngang thôi Ví dụ ở đây loại tiền ngửi
chúng ta nhập vào biểu tượng Center đây
Nhập vào nó cân giữa theo chiều ngang
này còn bây giờ chúng ta muốn cân giữa
theo chiều dọc này nữa này ha thì chúng
ta phải dùng cái công cụ của bạn chúng
ta chọn nguyên dòng vào lệnh vào thẻ là
table layout và chúng ta chọn lệnh đây
khung alignment chúng ta chọn lệnh ở
giữa đó là vừa canh giữa theo chiều
ngang và vừa canh giữa theo chiều dọc
chúng ta nhắc chuột đy thì lúc này chúng
ta quan sát là cái loại tiền gửi này n
nó vừa canh giữa theo chiều ngang và vừa
canh giữa theo chiều chiều dọc n đó là
thao tác định dạng và tiếp tục là cái
dòng tiêu đề tiêu đề là biểu lãi suất
ngoà tề và vàng đượcc n đồng thì cái
dòng tiêu đề này á là chúng ta sẽ dùng
cái hiệu ứng một chút chúng ta chọn dòng
chúng ta vào thẻ home chúng ta chọn hiệu
ứng ở đây add effect và chúng ta chọn
kiểu nhập chột vào rồi chúng ta có thể
tăng size lên một chút hoặc là chúng ta
16 16 hoặc 18 được đy rồi và như vậy Kết
thúc ở đây thì mới thì trên bài các bạn
cái thao tác là tạo bản và một số thao
tác định dạng cơ bản với đối tượng tbo
này Cái bài sau sẽ giới thiệu chi tiết
hơn về những cái thao tác với cái bản
này nhiều hơn một chút
nữa video này đến đây kết thúc và xin
chào các bạn